and that was an extraordinary experience
and very few people go through just the
utter misery of going to a place where
you think no matter how nice people are
to me they don't know what this is like
because so people have been there
and where your childhood just pins
and it impacts your sense of humor so I
love other people with a sense of humor
but I'm very aware that I didn't
practice mine very well as a young
person and I had to go looking for
answers to the big questions I couldn't
avoid them they were there and I thought
this is either going to sink me
or I'm going to find a resolution find a
way through we're very judgmental when
we say you're a victim and you're not a
victim because we don't know what other
people have been through you know I mean
I don't know what tough times and you
know I know a little of your story back
in Russia that wasn't easy you know and
people could say oh look at this
privileged Westerner in London living it
up and he's got millions of followers so
in my case my parents lives badly
interrupted badly by the second world
war
um so marriage was very delayed for them
I was born 10 years after the war I'm a
mid baby boomer my mother died very
shortly afterwards of undiagnosed
stomach cancer leaving my sister and me
is very young
and that was very tough for my father
really tough I mean we lived in a fairly
isolated partner of Australia
anyway we were sent off to boarding
school because that's what you had to do
when you got to age 11 or 12 in Sydney
and home on holidays and my father was a
um
a very gifted Sportsman so every
afternoon he was a good dad in this
sense would go off Target practicing we
had a rabbit plague in Australia so we'd
be popping off rabbits along the Creeks
or would be boxing he was a printed
boxer always be playing cricket because
he was a brilliant cricketer
staggeringly a good eye for Bull and
um as a teenager we were practicing
Cricket during one Easter break
and I was building my father all over
the place and he had that smile that a
father gets when he sees his kids really
latched on to something and then it all
went horribly horribly wrong
and I hit a six and my slightly younger
sister were very close to an age I was
watching from Sidelines a long way away
playing with a cat and she looked up and
saw my sixth Stitcher coming straight
for her and instinctively turned away
and that the ball quarter in the back of
the neck and she staggered a few feet
towards my father and called out and
died
and that was an extraordinary experience
and very few people go through where
you've been the innocent cause of
someone else's death and I was innocent
and I don't say for a moment I had a
guilt up hangover just the utter misery
of going to a place where you think no
matter how nice people are to me they
don't know what this is like because so
few people have been there and where
your childhood just ends
and it impacts your sense of humor so I
love other people with a sense of humor
but I'm very aware that I didn't
practice mine very well as a young
person and I had to go looking for
answers to the big questions I couldn't
avoid them they were there and I thought
this is either going to sink me
or I'm going to find a resolution and
find a way through and for me that was
the source really
from a thoroughly secular family I
suppose you'd say of me coming to
personal faith as a Christian believer
wow and
was that then your faith a platform for
you to be able to go and succeed in life
as your faith always been the Bedrock
for you
I think the answer to that is yes and I
think in many ways
the thing it's done most For Me Against
the Grain of my own nature
I think is to say
that my neighbor matters
and that I should be careful not about
so much judging their actions sometimes
they can be as tough as you like in
saying to others I think that's a bad
thing to do but not to write them off as
people and to say that if I matter
because a part of this journey for me
was to discover that this was not the
way it was meant to be God intended
things to be better that's my belief
that standard Christian belief we broke
it by our own selfishness but
as part of that the the the the Deep
desire to see others flourish under
participate in a society where you're
building not pair tearing down become a
very strong motivation for me
and I sometimes think to myself
I feel the hurt of unwarranted I've
never had much trouble coping with
deserved criticism but when it's
undeserved or unfair or unjustified or
people wrong motivation to me I've
always found that hard
because quickly enough I've actually
been very deeply committed to the idea
of trying to help build a better world
and John as we sit here recording this
we've just spent a few weeks in America
and in America people are very
comfortable expressing their religious
Faith openly but with you I sense of
hesitation is that just because you're
sitting here with two filthy agnostics
or or is there are we now you know in
Australia and Britain are we a little
bit more hesitant perhaps to talk about
things like that do you think uh look
there is a fair bit of that no it's not
you guys I know you're in trust you and
care enough about you to know that
anything is about me will be good
natured it will once
he doesn't know you that much I've got a
division here you know always looks of a
division yeah I'm an ex-politician yeah
um uh look I'm just aware that my story
can be you know it's a hard one to tell
uh it is to talk about those things
openly I'll tell you partly why I do it
more recently it's because I've seen
Jordan Peterson addressing
packed houses as mainly younger people
and I've noticed that young men in
particular respond when he tells them
that life's tough and it's gritty uh and
don't pretend otherwise and that truth I
think his line is truth is the antidote
to suffering and as I've watched in
Australia those young men responding to
him I'm thinking they're wanting what I
would say is a real steak not thin gruel
they're wanting to know other people's
experiences they want to know the
unvarnished truth
um and I suppose that's that's part of
why I tell it but the other part of it
is that I know that a lot of people
particularly not so much in America but
in Australia and in Britain will say oh
we've moved on from that HUD you know
John you're just being superstitious
it's rubbish and so forth but to me it
is the core of my being I had to answer
three very tough questions after that
what is this suffering why is suffering
so real
you know and secondly does anybody care
does anybody understand
and thirdly will the words be bound up
will there be Joy
and I think the answer to those three
questions in short or is
um no this is not the way it was meant
to be but we broke the world and people
will sort of say what are you talking
about original sin and I suppose yes I
am uh and it's not a complete
explanation in my case why did I live in
my sister not live I don't know I hope I
may won't know one day but here's the
point
what would really kill me would be the
idea to think it was just totally random
no purpose you just have all this pain
because that's the way life is and that
was the way it was always meant to be no
I don't believe it was meant to be like
that secondly can it be restored does
anybody care can it be restored second
part of the Triangle Well I believe yes
I do believe the Christian message of
redemption I do believe that the most
central figure in history is Christ
and he suffered
in every way in a way that's beyond
anything I might suffer a new alienation
then rejection by his friends more than
anything I might know
um so he can identify uh and because of
his actions I I do believe the words can
be bound up and that there is hope and I
look around and I see a desperate lack
of Hope
it really really troubles me I used to
see it all the time as an MP in the
really disadvantaged parts of my
electorate including and this is a
sensitive issue in Australia amongst
indigenous kids and I'd see them in the
school and their lives being
you know pissed up against the wall by
what was happening at home in their
community and I'm sorry to say that even
in the schools despite well-meaning
teachers and you think this is just a
dead end Street no wonder they've got no
hope
and hope is so important we don't talk
about it enough no we don't and with
that religious bit that we just did we
lost all our British audience but
welcome Americans it's good to have you
on board
foreign